the eve of england's second lockdown and
the pm
to parliament to seek approval for his
plan will your mps back your lockdown
prime minister
yes but reluctantly a rebellion
guaranteed
his party and the public frustrated
prime minister
the pm hopes this lockdown will be short
and sharp
of course i can't say exactly where the
epidemiology will be
by the second of december but what i can
say
is that the national measures that i
hope the house will vote on
tonight are time limited
they legally expire so whatever we do
from the second of december will require
a fresh mandate and a fresh vote
from this house and as i have made clear
it is my express intent that we should
return
to a tiered system labor skeptical mr
johnson's regional plan will work
to go back to that system doesn't make
any sense and for heaven's sake we've
got to use the next four weeks to come
up with something better than that
for the 2nd of december i can predict
what's going to happen because it's
happened so many times in the last 7
months
the prime minister says x won't happen x
will happen it does happen
and we start all over again but concede
in this lockdown now
a necessary evil while these regulations
are not in any way desirable or perfect
they are now necessary because the
government's lost control of the virus
and we will support them
qualified support from labour but plenty
of unhappiness from his own mps
not that the pm stuck around to hear it
jobs lost
livelihoods shattered businesses failing
whole sector's damage this decision i
believe was not necessary now
i will oppose it tonight when i vote
against this motion
tonight i'll do so with greater
conviction than i have in casting any
vote
this hurts my head and it hurts
my heart but the pm gets in his way for
now
the eyes have it the eyes have it
england into lockdown at midnight the
vote passing overwhelmingly
today but be in no doubt about the
febrile mood in the conservative
party over 50 tory mps declined to
support
the prime minister and they're warning
him that if he tries to extend this
lockdown beyond december
the second he's going to face a very
unhappy christmas
indeed if this doesn't work the pm will
have to find
a plan b i think this was a one-shot
lockdown this this
second shot perhaps lockdown i just
don't see the government being able to
come back
for another lockdown but this this is
very very high stakes for everyone
the pm struggling to get his mps to
comply
number 10 deeply worried that in the
coming weeks the public may not comply
either with all the obvious risk that
entails
beth rigby sky news westminster